it was her style
professional genuine humble caring that
earned her reporting and Shireen herself
the admiration and respect of millions
of viewers
was shot dead by an Israeli sniper on
May the 11th 2022
she was on assignment in Janine in the
occupied West Bank
after being rushed to hospital she was
declared dead at 7 13 am
from her colleagues shock grief
disbelief
was a familiar name in the arabic
speaking world
[Applause]
the large numbers that turned out for
her funeral were testimony to how loved
she was
it's rare for a journalists to have this
kind of an impact
known as the voice of Palestine even in
death Shireen continued to tell the
story of the Palestinian people
Israeli forces beat mourners at her
funeral procession
almost causing shireen's coffin to fall
to the ground
[Applause]
these images prompted International
condemnation from the United States to
France and the Vatican it appears the
Israelis didn't want her coffin to be
carried by the people
or for the Palestinian flag to be flown
shireen's family has campaigned
tirelessly for justice approaching the
White House the international criminal
court the European Parliament the
Vatican and the United Nations General
Assembly
said it was
mulger but that it was an accident and
no further action would be taken
however several independent
investigations found that the shot was
fired by a sniper and that Shireen was
deliberately targeted
was a high-profile Palestinian but
despite holding dual nationality with an
American passport despite being a
well-known journalist backed by a global
media Network and despite her family
lobbying at the highest levels
one year on there is no accountability
for her killing and no sign that her
killer
will ever be brought to Justice
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera at Al
jazeera's headquarters in Doha
so let's speak now to Nida Ibrahim who's
live for us there in Janae Nida so as
we're saying there it's been a year
since Shireen was killed by an Israeli
snipe but what's the atmosphere like
there today where are you and how will
people be remembering Shareen
I am at the place where Shireen was when
she was shocked by Israeli soldiers as
she was trying to report on a story on
an Israeli raid here in Janine at the
outskirts of the Janine refugee camp
she's remembered fondly she's remembered
as someone who didn't want to leave any
story Untold she was here at 6 30 in the
morning very early on trying to chase a
story as the Israeli forces came here
she took Refuge
industry when Israeli snipers targeted
her shot her even when she was wearing
her press best you know Shirin was
someone who was Keen to have the
security of the team first and foremost
before reporting she's someone who knew
the ground who knew the story so she
wasn't putting herself in danger she was
someone who was
trying to tell the story
when she was silenced Nita what about
your own personal thoughts I mean you
knew Shareen very well how did her
killing impact you and and the work
you're doing there on the ground
not just for me but for many other
Palestinian journalists she was the role
model she was the person you would look
up to the kind of Journalism you want to
do the accuracy the dedication the
passion she represented all of that not
just to me to many Palestinian
journalists and in particular the team
that has worked for her for more than 20
years and as I'm speaking to you now
there's an Israeli raid in another a
city here in the occupied West Bank in
tulkarim so that raids the Israeli raids
that have been after Shireen was killed
and during they were they're becoming
more regular they're becoming deadlier
so it's becoming scarier for us you can
imagine the tension for us as teams
working on the ground when we know that
someone we've worked with someone who is
that sincere highly respected someone
who would tell the story she was a
household name and no one was held
accountable when she was killed you can
imagine the stress we're under as
journalists trying to tell the story
when I talked to my fellow journalists
they say that they feel scared
traumatized and that their death won't
even matter if something happened to
them let me get a final thought from you
Nida I mean the Palestinian Authority
has taken the results of its own
investigation uh into her death to the
international criminal court the ICC do
Palestinians think that Shireen will
ever get Justice is there any hope that
anyone will ever be held accountable for
her killing
you know many were saying when she was
killed that Justice for Shireen means
justice for all the Palestinians that
she's reported on because it shows the
world the violations of the Israeli
occupation that has been going on for
decades but if you ask people really do
they believe that they were gonna get
any justice when it comes to her killing
the answer is no many Palestinians would
tell you that Israel has been getting
away with killing Palestinians for a
decade and the fact that one year on no
one has been held accountable it gives
Palestinians the idea that it's not
gonna that Justice is not going to be
achieved so as many Palestinians will
tell you they feel that the
International Community is even also
complicit in the fact that it's allowing
Israel to get away with murder
all right Al jazeera's Nita Ibrahim
there live from Janine at the very spot
uh where Al Jazeera journalist Shireen
Abba arclay was killed exactly a year
ago Nida thank you very much for your
Insight let's bring in Omar badah he's a
Middle East analyst who joins us live
from Washington DC Omar so uh Shireen as
uh Nita was saying there still nobody's
been held accountable for shireen's
death even though Israel says if
soldiers may have killed her do you
think anyone will ever be held
accountable will there be Justice for
her
look I mean there's no doubt about who's
responsible for her murder and it's
quite frankly frustrating and quite
shameful for the Biden Administration to
still be dragging its feet in terms of
doing anything about this an American
citizen and a renowned journalist was
killed by a foreign military and that
foreign military is funded by the US
government and the fact that we have not
seen any more meaningful action from the
US government right now
um is is deeply problematic I mean when
you think of uh somebody like Evan
gertvich uh who is being held in Russia
an American reporter for the Wall Street
Journal and how swift the American
reaction was or when you think about
Jamal khashukshi who wasn't even an
American citizen but a writer who lived
in the United States running for the
Washington Post and the way he was
murdered by the Saudi government and how
swift
um the condemnation and the conclusion
of the investigation holding the Saudi
government responsible for his killing
in the case of Syrian we have a much
clearer case of somebody who was
murdered on tape by sniper and the fact
that nothing has happened yet and that
we're still waiting to figure out what
really happened is it was silly yeah
Omar it's an interesting point you make
about the U.S response to shireen's
killing as you say she was a U.S citizen
Washington has put no pressure on Israel
the state department came out last year
with a statement saying the killing was
likely unintentional what more should
the U.S what more can the U.S do at this
stage
there needs to be you know the button
Administration was pressured into
allowing for our independent and FBI
investigation into the killing but that
investigation is moving at an incredibly
slow pace and it's inexcusable it's
obviously been politicized and there
needs to be pressure to get that
investigation to conclude and for Action
to be taken based on the fightings that
we all know everybody knows that she was
killed by a sniper that she was
deliberately targeted that she was
wearing a press vest that a sniper hit
her in the tiny spot that her head was
exposed all of this is pointing to a
very clear and deliberate murder and
what needs to happen is Meaningful
accountability in the form of frankly
Beyond just Shireen but you know you
can't keep funding a foreign military
that murders journalists and the fact
that the US gives the Israeli military
3.8 billion dollars every year in
military funding is really inexcusable
in the face of many crimes that were
committed against Palestinians
so let's just speak a little bit more
than about meaningful accountability
because Al Jazeera said it would file a
case with the international criminal
court the Palestinian Authority the PA
took the results of its own
investigation to the ICC but is that
going to be enough to bring her Killers
to Justice I mean has the international
legal system failed Shireen do you think
I mean you do have a fundamental problem
here in that there have been resolution
after resolution passed by the United
Nations investigation after
investigation into Israel's crimes
against Palestinians and accountability
never comes and that's for a simple
reason and that is the fact that the U.S
steps in to prevent meaningful
accountability for Israel the United
States has used its veto more than 50
times to block International
accountability for Israel uh and
intervenes at you know puts pressure on
the international criminal court to try
to stifle investigations of Israeli
crimes you have a system in which the
world's superpower is intervening
repeatedly to ensure that Israel is a
country above the law and that its
crimes are never you know nobody's ever
brought to justice for them and that is
I think what the fundamental reality has
to change in order for us to see the
possibility for accountability for this
murder and as long as we live in an
environment in which the US government
can get away with this kind of
um favorable you know exceptional
treatment for Israel putting it above
the law it's going to be very difficult
to see accountability let me get a final
brief point from you I mean the timing
of the anniversary of shireen's death is
significant isn't it I mean we're now
seeing an escalation the violence
between Israel and Islamic Jihad in Gaza
more Palestinians are being killed
Israel has a more extreme right-wing
government which many people say is
intent on suppressing the very
Collective Palestinian national identity
so what what hope is there then for
Palestinians what does the future hold
for them do you think
yeah we have the reality right now is
that we're marking the 75th anniversary
of the neckba a lot of people think of
the neck about as a historical event in
which Israel displaced three quarters of
the Palestinian population and destroyed
hundreds of villages uh to create the
state of Israel but it really is not a
historical event it's an ongoing reality
that this campaign of ethnic funding and
mass killings of Palestinians is
actually ongoing
um for their for the people who are
experiencing this on the ground the
reality is very very difficult and I'm
sure that it's difficult to find signs
of Hope but the reality is the
international discourse on this issue
the blatancy with which Israel is
behaving
um you know you just can't hide it
anymore and there is a global Awakening
that is happening that I believe is
going to lead to more and more
International solidarity with
Palestinians a growth of the boycott
divestment and sanctions movement
targeting Israel and that will one day
reach the point to where Israel can't
just get away with this Behavior anymore
it's going to take a while but we are on
the path of getting there Palestinians
deserve freedom and they are going to
get it Emma but uh really good to get
your thoughts and your analysis thank
you very much India for talking to us
Omar thank you
thank you